- [Narrator] Let's say that
you have a jar of jelly beans,
and you know that there
are exactly 282 jelly beans
in that jar of jelly beans.
And then the next day you come
and you see there are fewer
and you say, what happened,
and let's say someone
who lives with you or
your friend says, oh yeah,
I counted exactly and I ate
59 of those jelly beans.
So you started with 282, 59 are taken out,
and you don't need to know
exactly how many jelly beans
are left, but you wanna estimate roughly
how many jelly beans are
left, and that's why,
as this title of the video says,
we're going to estimate when
subtracting large numbers.
And we can debate how large is large,
but these are reasonably large.
So let's do that, let's
see if we can estimate
what 282 minus 59 is.
And sometimes when we're estimating,
we will use this squiggly equal sign.
This means approximately,
which is another,
just a fancy way of saying
roughly what is this equal to.
So the way that I would
approach this, I would say hey,
are these close to numbers that
are easier to subtract with.
So for example, 282,
I'd say, you know what,
maybe I can round to the nearest 10 here,
and so I could round it
down to 280, if I round down
to the nearest 10.
If I rounded up, it would
be 290, but 282 is closer
to 280 than it is to 290.
So I would round this,
when I'm estimating to 280.
And then what about 59?
If I were to round to the nearest 10,
what would I round that to?
Pause the video and think about that.
Well, 59 if I round
down to the nearest 10,
it would be 50, and if I
round up to the nearest 10,
it would be 60, and 59 is
definitely closer to 60.
So I would say that this is
roughly, if I'm rounding,
I could say, hey I'm
gonna round that to 60.
So I could say the 282
minus 59 is roughly going
to be 280 minus 60.
And now what is this?
You might be able to do this in your head.
You could view this as
28 tens minus six tens,
and so if you have 28 of
something minus six of it,
you're going to be left
with 22 of that something.
And so you could say that
this is going to be 22 tens.
22 tens, or another way to think about it.
You have two 100s and then 8 tens,
and then you're gonna take
six tens away from it,
so then you'll be left
with two 100s and two tens.
Just like we have here.
So the whole point here, this is not,
this is actually not exactly
what 282 minus 59 is,
but if you just said, hey
ballpark do I, I wanna know,
do I have roughly how many
jelly beans do I have,
well this could be useful.
And you'll see later in
life this is actually
a very, very usefully
skill where you might have
these numbers that get
a lot larger than this,
but you'll round to the nearest 10,
or you'll round to other places,
so that you can do that
computation in your head.